the hall-of-famer Kurt Warner on loan
from the NFL Network adjoining a soma
program good morning Kurt the Cowboys
have a new head coach what do you think
yeah I mean I just saw that you know
interesting for to me I mean I think one
part of it I think he's got a good
presence a big presence about it and
obviously won a Super Bowl so I think
that meshes well with what Jerry Jones
does there his presence there I think
the thing that maybe surprised me a
little bit is you have a lot of
innovation this year with with Kellen
Moore and you kind of thought with daca
and Zeke and what they wanted to be in a
kind of the nature of where the league
is going that they may get a younger guy
with more of that offensive flair to him
because I think the one knock on Mike
McCarthy went towards the end of his
time in Green Bay was he didn't have a
lot of that it was kind of a stagnant
offend him now I know he's done a lot
and researched a lot of a league and
maybe he's coming in with a lot of
innovation but that was the one part
that surprised me but understand it from
a present standpoint kind of coach you
need to be around Jerry Jones yeah I
just I'm curious about that relationship
but also more importantly the
relationship with a younger quarterback
who's not going to the Hall of Fame any
time soon as Aaron Rodgers is you got a
great running back as well I'm just
curious Mike McCarthy's offensive
philosophy if it didn't jibe with Aaron
Rodgers what makes you think it'll work
in in Dallas
yeah no I'm fully with you you know when
I watched it you know at Green Bay and
you just felt like a lot of it was
dependent on their quarterback and Aaron
Rodgers to make special plays now I
think that's where Aaron sometimes is
that his best and so maybe it catered
that direction because of him but I
agree with you I don't think Dax there
yet where he can continually create
opportunities in the passing game for
his team and so you have to create some
things for him and off of the running
game s Kellen Moore I thought did really
well early in the year and that's when
dak was playing his best so again I'm
fascinated by that part of it too and
what the offense will look like is he
going to bring somebody which kind of
that younger flair to to work with him
on that
I'm interested to see how that all plays
out where is Tom Brady playing next year
in your opinion I to me he's either
playing in New England or he's not
playing and you know I kind of took that
you know when he made that comment like
you know hopefully unlikely I think is
what he said in his press conference
hopefully unlikely that he's retiring
that to me meant hopefully we get
something done here in New England where
I don't have to retire because I can't
come back here I just I think it's so
hard to go somewhere else especially
when you look at different situations
around the league and think you're going
to have the success that they had in New
England or the standard of excellence
that tom has set to expect that in
another place quickly you know it's
always a process in building a culture
and building a standard of excellence
and I don't know if there's a a fit out
there that I go oh well he goes here
they automatically you know with what
they have around him would be a
championship contender and I'm just not
sure Tom wants to go and be a part of
that kind of rebuilding and does he have
enough time left to feel like he can
rebuild even if it takes you know two
three years you know tops yeah I look at
the Chargers and maybe it's just wishful
thinking from folks in Los Angeles that
go yeah he'd be the perfect quarterback
and we've got all these toys you got a
good tight end you got two good wide
receivers a couple of running backs
there and you put him in and we move
into a new stadium I mean it all sounds
like a Hollywood ending there I just
don't know if I'm with you I think Brady
either plays with the Patriots or he
doesn't play again but I don't know if
there's part of him that says hmm maybe
I haven't gotten as much credit as I
deserve or let me show them that which
is dangerous but you know egos do play a
role here and maybe Belichick saying
yeah yeah I'm the genius here I can I
can build this again with somebody else
because we don't look at age with a
coach the way we look at age as a
quarterback so we think the Belichick
can coach five more years in age doesn't
have anything to do with it I fully
agree there's no question ego plays into
to all of us as players competitors
whatever we do when worth
of our game yeah ego plays into it and I
I fully believe that there would be a
part if the parting did happen that both
of them would relish here let me show
what I mean to an organization or what I
meant to that New England organization
outside of the other guy but as you said
I think it's very dangerous territory
because if the split happens and either
aren't successful now they are looked
upon possibly a little bit differently
than they were during their time
together so I agree
you know competitors ego all of that
stuff says yeah let me go show everybody
I can do it somewhere else
but I just think as you said dangerous
big picture legacy question as well and
not that maybe either of them are even
worried about that but I do think that
comes into play when we're talking about
ego as well NFL Network analyst Westwood
one analyst and Hall of Fame quarterback
Kurt Warner joining us on the show
comfortable with the pass interference
not being called on Kyle Rudolph and
that game winning score not really
because we because we have it in place I
just really felt like that's the moment
that's why we put it in place and I
understand they were hand fighting a
little bit if you want to call it
offsetting call it offsetting as I saw a
couple times this year but he fully
extended a hand and he fully got
separation and pushed the DB back on
again the biggest play in the playoffs
up to that point so you were over
overturned then I would have yeah I I
think it was obvious pass interference
and let them go play another down and
again I understand all year long it's
been what it's been and I think a lot of
us feel like it's been a sham from the
get-go that they weren't really going to
to call it like we thought they were
going to call it and it got to the point
where they weren't overturning anything
I get all of that but to me that was the
moment that you put it in for and I did
feel like there was a definite offensive
advantage where the defender and I look
at it the opposite way if I felt the
defender did that same thing and push
the offensive God and made the
interception I think without a doubt
they throw that flag
me you have to flip it and say the same
thing with the ball in the air and I
thought they should have overturned and
let him go again give me the road team
since we had three road teams win this
weekend and another road team that went
into overtime give me the road team that
you like the best to pull off the win
this next weekend I guess I have to say
Seattle you know again I think Minnesota
may be the best team top-to-bottom going
anywhere I just want to see it a couple
weeks in a row for them to play like
they did yesterday I mean they dominated
I thought in a lot of phases yesterday I
want to see that again going on the road
to San Francisco I look at Green Bay and
I say they're good team not a great team
and you know with Russell Wilson they
always find ways to keep it close so I
just feel like that could be nature with
the weather and all that stuff a closed
football game where Russell Wilson could
have that one possession to do what he
does so well and possibly pull off the
upset yeah and we just had Kirk Cousins
on and I said no matter what you do
during the regular season just like Tony
Romo like we don't care he could throw
for 40 touchdowns good throw for 50 and
you just say yeah but let me see what
you do in the plant like Matt Stafford
and even though you had that win against
New Orleans in that building for a 13
win team I think the critics are still
going yeah but you know right and I
think everybody wants to see to like I
always kind of gauge a franchise
quarterback by situations where you have
to carry your team with your right arm
in the biggest moments nothing else is
going on and you've got to go swing for
swing with another guy and you know I
still think we're kind of waiting for
that with Kirk I thought it was just a
perfect game the way it played out and I
thought he played an unbelievable game
yesterday but the game was close
throughout he was never asked to have to
carry that team drove or throw and I
think that's what we want to see you
know that to me is what puts you over
the top when you can look at a guy and
go oh my gosh there it is right there he
threw 45 times they needed every throw
and he made every throw to get a big win
for his team against another great
quarterback or
the playoffs yeah I think you're right
we're still looking and saying okay you
still got to do more in the playoffs to
get your do good to talk to your Kurt my
best to the family and we appreciate
your time as always thanks my man Kurt
Warner NFL Network analysts of course
Hall of Fame quarterback for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]